tu as dit on et quand tu dis des trucs
mal et on est les anciens nouveaux
comics va pas lui fait remarquer qu'il
dit des trucs comme ça quand même
on est d'accord mais si on est des
anciens nouveaux comiques s'est endettée
nouveau comique battant les anciennes
ouais les inconnus c'est des
révolutionnaires j'ai lu dans le journal
ont séparé ces cerveaux 206 et moi de
vous interrompre un passionné je suis de
7 dt mois
ouais mon comité d'entreprise la
boucherie chevaline
on est aussi né tout dénigrer
[Applaudissements]
le terme est notée ramponneau si c'est
tout bête à savoir prendre cinq minutes
à moi je me permets d'être relâché venu
voir si j'aime bien les inconnus quoi
j'aime bien ce que vous faites un c'est
formidable
le pilote je voyais des personnes
d'obédience judaïque ça nous fait un
point commun ce dossier dindane
show-business fabre non je suis étonné
qu'une personne les personnes de couleur
la joie seulement j'ai près il s'essaie
de personnels appellent dieu donnez vous
ne vous êtes pas pauline jeu c'est moche
c'est l'attitude que vous avez études et
moi voilà tout ce barouf au comptant six
mois et tout respecter les lois mais le
salon ouais t'es un beau [ __ ] ouais tu
dis ça devant le char de temps oui mais
ça devant tiers des 140 km h est née
d'un pays que tout est à moins de 19 ans
du trône et répondu qu'il pense du fond
qu'à la nativité importe quoi
je m'attendais sans moi avec tout le
respect que je vous dois quelque chose
elle était un peu vous [ __ ] autorisé
mois n'ont pas souvent qu'il est laurent
battut demande que ça moi j'essaie
d'arrêter non merci je n'en veux pas du
boeuf et j'en veux pas de calais deux
mois de bourse c'est en groupe gt de moi
tout le respect que je vous dois et
gemma pulsions pantaloni je prends une
belle tu pas un animal mais bon on n'ose
plan dit de partir de bornes au splendid
lille à partir du corps je ne connais
pas va pas être content à partir donc à
partir de maintenant 1 à 22 heures tous
les soirs mais normalement tu es censé
être un comique fin tu veux bosser là
dedans ou pas bah oui c'est vrai que
pour moi ça n'a pas toujours été facile
au guatemala un bon déjà bon ben je suis
né dans une banlieue un petit peu
qu'elle gabon c'était difficile j'ai
essayé de m'en sortir
il ya eu cet état d'un bond de petites
filles conduit la boulette
j'ai payé je suis chez moi et tout le
respect que je vous dois vous étiez vous
en sortir en part par le biais de
l'expression théâtrale ont fait des
pardons de la petite fille dont il est
une vieille histoire études moi c'est
moi qu'est ce que tu fais de remuer le
passé et à ses marques 1
enfin bon bref bon ben c'était juste
pour mettre 10 ans
un point pour la cfdt les parce que moi
chez la cfdt bon on a il y en a des
problèmes
bon ben on a des le monde tous les
travailleurs salariés tombons dans la
boucherie chevaline ça va pas nous moi
je moi je suis dans l'accueil de la fin
sur la tétine de chat on a des problèmes
bon tu sais tout simplement on est venu
juste pour ça c'est tout pas si on sait
que l'émission est en direct ne se sera
pas coupée à ça c'est pas plus dévoué et
un jours merci d'une mission là-bas
merci à tous les abus et comment
d'accord bomba après tout le service
public est ouvert à tout le monde
le service public c'est la télévision du
public qui est bien la finance et ses
cryptes et donc les mêmes équipes à ce
point tout le monde peut s'exprimer
[Applaudissements]
le soir
j'ai une question à vous poser c'est
tout bête pourquoi vous êtes deux on est
on est plus drôle à 2 parce qu'il y
avait une troisième personne mais on l'a
éliminée et on a dévoré lequel des deux
est le plus drôle
j'aurais tendance à dire moi
mais je serai pas objectif je sais que
c'est fait je voudrais bien voir ça
tient les 8 à albi manger ensemble
si vous n'étiez pas ensemble avec quel
comique aimeriez vous travailler fois le
petit par exemple charles pasqua mais
non non non et non
[Rires]
et toi le plus gros enfin le modèle le
plus musclé voyez-les y ait quelqu'un ça
vous aurez plus de faire les noeuds
carrière aux trembles et noir et blanc
ah oui moi ça n'aurait plus c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'on est ensemble et
en noir et blanc c'est peut-être chez
pas oui sénégalais du muet même c'est
vrai que non on avait l'intention de
faire ça et ça ne plaisait pas aux
chaînes
[Applaudissements]
par contre les autres laurent ruquier
non france inter n'ont jamais croisé un
petit peu largué jean pierre coffe tf1
jean pierre coffe vous êtes danseur
saloper samedi vaguement quelque chose
bonsoir en tout cas huit mois dans les
lycées qui s'est pas dieudonné vous êtes
bien bronzé vous dites oui j'étais
voir les nos amis les arabes oui j'ai
été à marrakech
oui j'ai fait un petit break dans mon
spectacle et c'est l'arrivée du soleil
il neigeait pas ouais c'est à dire que
ce spectacle donc été prévu pour durer
tout est prévu en avril en avril et ben
apparemment puisque les gens apparemment
apprécié josiane les gens viennent gens
qui viennent des gens qui sont là comme
s'était bien est ce qu'on va manger
comme ça ouais tous les soirs bay 6
alors j'essaie donc jusqu'au 19 juin ces
données on peut ce spectacle c
ces 100 francs pour les étudiants ah
ouais et non 160 35 ans plus de thunes
j'ai mal j'ai béni 190 mois s'est mis en
scène par muriel robin c'est votre amie
muriel robin oui oui c'est ma cote les
commençants 100 bars avec roger louret
qui maintenant fait les années tubes
avec gérard louvin sur tf1 roger louret
avec la bande des années tubes nous
aimons beaucoup ici je dois dire et
alors vous étiez dans un spectacle ça
s'appelait les balades de la jeune et à
les baladins en agenais un truc mais
j'essaie quand j'étais petit j'avais 19
ans ouais et alors le spectacle s'est
elle est folle amoureuse de regnard
c'était quoi le régnard bas c'est un
auteur du xviie siècle
c'est sûrement un copain de molière face
and i'm still et moi je faisais un petit
valet et muriel robin c'est la jeune
première
je faisais la genevoise r oui moi j'ai
vu robin au zénith
la semaine dernière elle est
exceptionnelle son nouveau spectacle
faut le dire parce que vraiment si vous
avez l'occasion de la voir en spectacle
c'est le meilleur one woman show qu'elle
ait fait je pense avait perdu les autres
mais même si cela est formidable parce
que moi aussi j'ai une oreillette
alors je suis en train de vie pose moins
de questions à temps ouais ouais nan
parce que je veux montrer aux
téléspectateurs voilà j'ai ça dans le
rail c'est bien que les gens ne sachent
pas ce matin l'a pas dit donc oui
d'accord je lui demande combien il a
vendu deux cassettes d'accord la salle
est vendu combien de cas cette date
je pense qu'on n'est pas loin des 300
mille ans a lui augmenté de 8 août et je
pense à la savate rien soyons contents
et là vous avez sorti un livre si on me
demande de vous de vous demander si on
me demande moi de ne pas vous répondre
non je suis moi aussi je veux bien lui
répondre son bouquin hockey ouais ça ne
me dérangera pas franchement d'accord je
lui dit non mais si c'est comme ça je
l'enlève ainsi c'est pour me dire ce
qu'il faut dire pendant toute l'émission
je vais l'enlever tout de suite
bon donc aujourd'hui mais j'ai entendu
j'entends france inter
on autorise aux motoristes donc à vous
demander ce n'est pas l'immobilisme tu
te remets où tu veux parce que moi je me
demandais où fans et de mètres on a fait
des abbassides
autoliv s'appelle plaisanterie si
lamentable ça ça s'appelle plaisanterie
swiss est un recueil de poésie dans la
poésie
quand j'étais jeune pour séduire les
jeunes filles chirac river des poèmes où
ça comme susceptible et écrire un truc à
une belle phrase d'ailleurs vous êtes et
petits c'était je la suite parce que
c'est vraiment eu des barthes achats
c'est un beau écoute l'eau ne sait pas
nager
la preuve elle coule ouais c'est qu'en
chine a crû au baccalauréat crois moi tu
l'ouvrés pas loin d'être philosophe oui
tout à fait c'est du berger sans que la
petite jeune fille commence à tomber
amoureuse d'achat elle s'appelle tâche à
cette tâche à 5 ans vous étiez petit
effectivement où tout le monde vous
casser la gueule y creuse de rock et
vous pouvez prendre pour résister pour
résister vous avez développé l'humour
si c'est ça c'est une chose que tu ne
connais pas non non non mais comme andy
schleck à l'arrivée
sur vous progressez document
alors donc vous avez déclaré j'en ai
marre comme invité à la télé en me
disant venez juste pour faire le con à
mes savez souvent arrivé dans la cour du
tout d'avoir dû votre spectacle déjà et
c'est pas fini votre lit match n'est pas
le cas du tout non mais souvent c'est
vrai que la télé ccc difficiles laurent
pourrait me le dire pour confirmer ce
que je dis c'est que quand on est
artiste on se fait bouffer par la télé
on sert de faire valoir aux animateurs
on est là à côté de gens qui font des
rubriques qui présentait ce clip ça à
faire des rappels noir aux artistes
alors dan en croit que les avaloirs à
l'autre maintenant on fait les vraies
émissions bien je pense c'est celle qui
met en valeur les artistes ont leurs
yeux on les laisse parler d'eux lors de
ce qu'ils font et ses îles sont pas
juste là parce qu'ils sont connus parce
qu'ils font parce qu'ils disent trois
conneries et qui déstabilise et les gens
enfin dans mon cas en tout cas on va
souvent appeler pour dire à vient faire
le con machin et lee addy jeu à la télé
on est de l'achat on en est de la chair
à audience on sert qu'à faire de
l'audience
alors on verra demain matin si vous êtes
de l'aventuré si vous êtes vraiment de
la chair à audience
ça nous apporte la célébrité la de
passer comme ça dans des talk shows la
télévision mais finalement c'est une
sorte de pacte avec le diable
bah oui c'est ce que je viens de dire
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
enfin c'est délicat quand on fait trop
de télé qu'on a envie de faire du cinéma
on peut pas faire de cinéma quand on
nous voit trop à la télé on fait plus
rêver les gens c'est vous qui n'aurait
pas parlé
alors oui ce monde donc si vous deviez
partir sur une île déserte et le film de
vous quel film que vous emporteriez vous
aulas va se dire j'ai fait que des
chefs-d'oeuvre alors c'est ça c'est
compliqué c'est vrai moi pas dans vos
films j'ai raconté mes blagues pour
pouvoir rire c'est moche comme attitude
j'avais vidé
c'est lui qui en a parlé mais on
n'aurait pas parlé vie c'est un moment
on avait demandé
on avait demandé de ne pas en parler
c'est lui qui en a parlé du cinéma j'ai
vu des films d'elie semoun jean-pierre
de qui des lycées à retenir c'est sympa
écoutez je vais vous dire que je n'ai
pas plus vu de film d'elie semoun tout
de qui que ce soit d'autre je suis allé
au cinéma depuis cyrano de bergerac
oui quand même un bon bain marie la
création de ce délit à part ça j'aime
énormément ce qui fait bon se trouve
c'est un type qui a beaucoup de talent
et puis que j'allais aussi les hôpitaux
c'était pas si mal le claude franchement
charity-business non plus c'était pas
mal ça j'ai passé un petit business
était un film avec smaïn mais c'était
oui c'était rigolo moi j'avais vu avec
ophélie winter
oui tout doit disparaître tout qu'un
titre dangereux c'est bien ça
as tu te souviens quand même extrêmement
bien de voir ça c'est un sketch mais
continuent quand il est seul sur scène
vous aimez ce genre de garçon d'achat je
pense que c'est qu'ils n'en artistes
donc j'espère que les garçons qui pour
vous drague il faut faire rire est ce
que pour vous draguez réputation vous
draguez il faut vous faire rire ah c'est
très important
le mot à mes mots en général je pense à
l'intelligence aussi l'intelligence
aussi il a nous a montré jeu là les deux
je ne peux pas vous montrer mon cerveau
mais en tout cas j'en ai à la cuisse à
l'ouverture chez spect'art revenons au
spectacle parce qu'on est là pour parler
de votre travail et pas juste pour vous
regarder faire dites moi vous avez
déclaré
c'est dur d'écrire seul il vous manque
votre ami non enfin au début il m'a
manqué forcément ça me déstabilise et
d'être 2 1 lorsqu'il est bien sans mais
sérieusement je sais aussi bien quand
vous étiez avec lui oui tout à fait oui
non mais sérieusement mai
oui au départ et maintenant qu
évidemment c'est vrai que là cette
séparation pour moi a été un peu plus
dur que pour lui j'en suis sûr mais mais
une fois que muriel robin a décidé de
s'occuper de mon spectacle mettre en
scène de ce spectacle je me suis sentie
complètement en confiance et j'ai plus
pensé à lui et c'est possible un jour
voir ensemble je sais pas franchement
c'est ce que vous avez dit sur lui ça
m'étonnerait que vous avez déclaré c'est
un ex vendeur de bagnols il était obsédé
par le pognon c'est pas sympa mais c'est
vrai oui
ouais c'est la vérité non ça lui fait
pas de la peine quand vous dites ça ça
lui fait pas de la paix non je crois pas
il aime ça il est c'est vrai que c'est
un homme d'affaires moi j'en suis pas du
tout va vous avez dit d'ailleurs oui
vous avez dit j'étais un peu lui c'était
un peu le juif du spectacle est moins
noir qui se fait avoir
oui c'est une blague mais ça c'est une
blague mais c'est la vérité c'est la
vérité c'est parti c'est ericsson n'est
pas tissé maximum d'ici là il a un truc
fort bien que vous n'êtes pas raciste de
l'évident amant mais vous jouez beaucoup
avec leurs assises mais vous êtes un d
un des seuls comics en france qui joue
avec le racing par exemple un jour on
vous demandait si dieudonné s'en va vous
dites si dieudonné s'en va je tape sur
une poubelle pour trouver un autre noir
par exemple comme c'est vous personne
derrière ça peut paraître méchant ou
est-ce que la vue comme ça c'est méchant
non mais moi de donner je laime je laime
beaucoup encore je trouve qu'il a
beaucoup de talent mais il est parti
dans un délire qui n'est pas le mien
quoi la politique les histoires d'argent
etc
c'est pas mon truc ouais que voilà c'est
tout
[Applaudissements]
on vous dit par exemple quand débute
avec les juifs les nazis en avec les
juifs les nazis ont pas fini le boulot
par exemple vous vous dites ça c'était
dans un sketch mais ça choque personne
c'est dieudonné qu'il disait dans un
sketch était un juif et un noir qui se
tapaient sur la gueule mais on est très
on a souvent pratiqué je la pratique
encore le l'autodérision je me souviens
qu'à l'époque on avait une affiche ou
moi j'étais en ss bien on sait c'est
dieudonné un cucs clan puis on se
serrait la main comme ça avec un grand
sourire
donc c'est un petit peu de la
provocation quoi pourquoi vous
choisissez l'inspecteur comme spectacle
l'inspecteur oui votre lotion ce sketch
mais pourquoi pas celle là dans ce
sketch là oui pourquoi
je vais vous dire en anglais ses
sketches en tout cas
c'est un
non justin que c'est un gars qui est en
garde à vue en fait ils parlent à un
commissaire et il est interrogé sur ce
qu'il a fait et on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
eu par exemple est-ce que vous avez été
arrêtés dans votre nom mais mon
spectacle en fait c'est tout mes
cauchemars
voilà c'est la mort la police la bêtise
le racisme des cauchemars c'est cette
nuit nous avons joué un peu joué avec
linda peuvent être le sampler j'ai déjà
commencé à jouer avec l'état on pouvait
jouer avec le sampler là vous faites
tout ce que je voulais avec elle wen de
quelle façon
comme vous voulez c'est lui qui décide
c'est le patron j'ai demandé d'enlever
ton petit pull oui oui c'est bien ça me
fiche bien si je pouvais enfin non mais
j'ai pas ça chez vous plus tard je sais
pas on verra à la il ya un petit blanc
l'a enfin te dire quelque chose et on me
dit peut-être vous pourriez quitter le
plateau parce que ça a bien marché la
semaine dernière quand bedos est partie
des missions du jeu non non je crois que
ça fait de l'audience
non non non non déjà là et d'une je
t'emmerde terry avec tout le respect que
je te dois je préfère rester là je suis
très bien ici
non c'est pas du jeu reste
[Applaudissements]
je reste eu envie de rester d'accord je
vais rester ici je suis très bien je
vais [ __ ] la merde je veux partir je
veux pas pourquoi je partirais non bah
ouais j'avais voulu poser des questions
à la con toi qui va se barrer bon et ça
les questions à la con bon elie donc
elie semoun au palais des glaces c'est
la promo qui commence la tension alors
les textes sont d'elie semoun tout à
fait il de franck dubosc et de muriel
robin ça je le dis à chaque fois que je
reçois dans une émission parce que ça me
fait rire vous étiez je viens à chaque
fois avec muriel robin dans la troupe
des baladins de l'agenais qui était du
troupeau inquiéter la troupe de roger
louret
non parce que j'imagine très bien avec
muriel robin dans les baladins de la
jeunesse sous la direction de roger
louret qui fait les années tubes et je
tiens à le féliciter d'ailleurs si vous
faites quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est à dire que moi j'étais habillé un
petit bouffon a laissé la jeune première
s'appelait folie amoureuse on en parlait
dans une langue qu'ils ne se parlent
plus qu'ils s'appellent le français
c'est une pièce classique lancé été
assez surréaliste où est maintenant avec
le avec le recul cette fois ci non non
ça va ces deux noms je tenais à préciser
pour option mais sur le service public
quand même que cette pièce et de regnard
aussi à travers peut-être intéresser les
gens on est un petit peu culturel en
même temps d'autres noms célèbres un peu
plus tueur est dans le temps alors dans
cette cassette qu'on voit à l'écran
pendant qu'on en parle 1 il ya douze
sketches
alors on verra tout à l'heure celui
qu'on a choisi nous qui s'appelle griffi
montbazon touche
ils sont tous assez insensé il y à 12
personnages et là on s'est mis vendredi
dernier avec ma femme au lit on a
regardé l'a47 parce qu'on savait que
vous êtes à femmes d'antan mali avec la
télé posée au bout du lit et on a mis la
cassette elie semoun et on a hurlé mais
de rire
déglacer tant mieux oui c'est aussi bien
oui c'est aussi bien mais là comment on
avait envie de se remettre de ce le
remettre en tête mais j'ai oublié une
question et dit quand on vous voit à la
télé comme ça on vous mettra un peu sous
un chapeau comme on dit chez moi si vous
êtes un peu cool calme pas très et dès
que vous entrez sur une scène vous êtes
complètement déjanté gravers que je suis
dessus pas perpétuellement
représentation c'est pas ça que je vais
bien non c'est pas ça bien entendu mais
là vous aviez différence entre les
autres
je suis fou dans la vie je suis normale
sur scène je suis pas normal clermont
bat normalement pas normal annonce qui
s'est trop long alors vous avez déclaré
elie semoun quand il ya certaines
phrases qui provoquent des hurlements
chez moi c'est moi
vous avez déclaré elie semoun l'humour
pour moi quand j'étais enfant je suis
désolé je suis désolé l'humour pour moi
quand j'étais petit c'était je vous
étiez un peu de chic lettres quoi preuve
d'un très bas très bas très bien gaulée
et vous avez déclaré donc l'humour pour
moi c'était comme des grands excuse moi
je suis désolé je vais déclarer la
rigolade pour moi c'est comme des gants
de boxe
ouais c'est à peu près ça ouais c'est
l'époque on vous appelez pupuce oui si
j'étais petit quand j'étais petit donc
donc on m'avait associé à une petite
fille qui s'appelait pupuce aussi quand
j'étais en colonie de vacances mais
mes copains élèves m'avait forcé à
l'embrasser sur la bouche et alors et l
humiliation de ma vie quoi vous êtes
bien placé jusque là que dès que les
garçons quoi voilà c'est ça quand
j'étais en sixième j'étais homosexuel et
puis
là vous
[Applaudissements]
j'appelle maintenant des photos de vous
justement à cette époque
s'ils voulaient bien prendre votre petit
teaser les regarde et vous avez mal et
que vous avez menées comme un sergé ce
qu'on peut passer en noir et blanc est
ce qu'on va passer elie semoun en noir
et blanc ça sera raccord avec l'époque
il a peur de passage était mignon alors
ça c'est qu'à l'époque c'est qu'à
l'époque ça ça c'était ya six mois
regarder son émission et sam abal ans
j'étais petit je sais pas quel âge avait
mais c'était à l'époque où je faisais
kaka dans ma culotte
voilà est ce qu'on peut voir la photo
suivante s'il vous plaît vous êtes bien
voilà c'est tout ça c'était à quel
endroit là c'est quand j'ai fait la
couverture de playboy 1 1
c'était je suis prêt c'est probablement
en vacances et
je ne sais pas franchement je sais pas
on va voir la troisième photo pascal
bats vous êtes vraiment comme
aujourd'hui voilà c'était à l'ironie
comme ça formidable
un petit chien est génial ouais très
joli il a rejoint il ya l'équipe était
bien et alors après vous avez bon vous
avez après cette époque là n'aura pas
c'est pas que j'ai passé un truc grave
votre mère a disparu donc est ce que
c'est en rencontrant dieudonné que vous
allez retrouver l'âme soeur non non non
il m'a pas servi dancer non non mais
c'est simplement que moi j'aime les
paradoxes dans la vie et je me suis dit
un petit juif un gros noir c'est rigolo
quoi alors et y'en a calé au boulot une
blonde à forte poitrine
eh bien
pas trop ces voies frère voilà tu restes
là toi ouais bon bah ça va alors ça vous
convient et mac
il est tout retourné bon alors
maintenant on va passer à l'interview
mensonges et j'aimerais serge qu'on
baisse a pu la lui attention images
fixes
vous ne bougez plus voilà alors elie
semoun l'interview mensonge comme
d'habitude à la télévision les
interviews vous répondez par des
mensonges c'est tout à fait habituel
génériques à la télé tous les cas les
gens ont un peu de mal mais voilà elie
semoun est ce que vous sautez toujours
tout ce qui bouge
non ça m'est arrivé dernièrement c'était
quand j'étais à l'école tu vas arrêter
tout ce qui vous difficile non madame
belpaire de l'offre est ce que vous êtes
toujours de droite
oui oui plus que jamais ouais j'aime
extrême droite extrême droite député du
front national de la région de dreux
elle présente contre dieudonné est ce
que vous êtes toujours antisémites et
lee c'est à dire c'est un petit peu
énervant a eu l'impression qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui me touchent enfin vendre à
force de chercher les blondes à fortes
oui c'est normal ça devait vous arrivez
alors je suis je suis antisémite ou et
je déteste les juifs
attention la ville et un début
d'érection mais vous allez faites
attention parce qu'après il se contrôle
plus toujours dans la finesse and well
gdp là je suis quoi comment vous trouvez
linda hardy
c'est un boudin c'est une bonne série c1
ces mensonges des manceaux et vous
comment vous trouvez physiquement très
beau est ce que vous avez donné pour le
téléthon pourquoi il ya quelqu'un à
chaque fois derrière qui fait là haut
comme si les gens pouvaient pas réagir
normal parce qu'il vous trouve beau
c'est je viens viens auguste chauffeur
de salle à ses chauffeurs de celle
d'avoir aucune sétois en fait qui a oui
voilà rochus il a un truc génial en jeu
sa formidable quand il veut que les gens
applaudissent il fait ça les i
[Applaudissements]
voila voila c'est la télé c'est
vachement à la télé c'est un truc super
spontanée quand même c'est génial bon et
lee ont continué l'interview mensonge
vous êtes à combien de pétards par jour
15 le matin 10 le midi trois le soir là
c'est pas mensonge est ce qu est ce que
vous trouvez ça bien de mentir
ouais j'adore c'est génial c'est gentil
un plus bas sans raison moi mon métier
génial de mentir bon j'essaye de voir si
j'ai pas une moue commencé sa toute
façon mal social compléments capillaires
uniquement c'est pour ça je te
demanderai de toucher uniquement cette
partie là je te remercie toi l'homme
bandar bin ouais bon une toute façon il
faut qu'on vous rendent à hollywood
night
je remercie etienne je te remercie de
nous avoir plus que l héroïne hollywood
night ce soir jack vous pouvez le
remarquer
encore
alors nous en garde mais on garde une
brune une brune une brune à forte tête
plutôt qu'un blonde à forte poitrine et
les on vous a vu pas mal au cinéma
beaucoup en 98 est ce que finalement
vous trouvez pas que les humoristes se
lancent un peu trop tôt dans une
carrière cinématographique
j'avais dit de faire parler de cinéma
non halal à ses pairs en garde
c'est vrai que j'ai fait un paquet de
films et qui sont pas tous bien
fonctionné mais l'a laissée
quand et comédien c'est difficile de
résister on propose de faire un film
avec un premier rôle en plus les films
que j'ai fait c'était avec smaïn que tu
connais apparemment que j'ai fais ce que
j'aime bien ensemble voilà vous avez
tourné ensemble que j'aime beaucoup mais
disons qu'on m'a jamais dit que j'étais
un mauvais acteur donc c'est ça qui
m'importe quoi
maintenant je suis patient j'attends on
va me proposer sûrement quelque chose de
bien où je pourrais vraiment m'éclater
et les on va passer maintenant à une
nouvelle interview sa peine dans une
interview ce bec on ne bouge pas
[Musique]
voilà alors chaque semaine on recevra
l'invité que nous recevrons lui posera
des questions il nous répondra dans une
langue étrangère qu'il maniait c'est
bien et vous c'est l'ouzbek seulement
avec les infos nécessaires bonne
sécurité sociale voilà parce que la
grand-mère délit on peut le dire
maintenant est né en ouzbékistan et lee
a été élevé par sa grand-mère et
s'épaissit quand vous les résidents
steinitz a alors dit amour l'amour
auquel baume ou non au foehn et époque
et ceara au fromage
et puis et puis à la vie on ne se
comprenait font que semer chez towers
basse et la mort savourant ce fim us est
ce que vous aimez les chiens c'est le
boom boom
oui quelle formidable quel formidable
cassette on rappelle les dates de votre
tournée peut-être pied funèbres
saint-etienne 3 octobre
de mulhouse sur un peu ses nerfs octobre
et marseille comme fin novembre
dernière question et lille bouvines
dernière question et et dieu dans tout
ça c'est qu'on en fait
pardon tes pronos ah bon alors avant de
longs peut rallumer la lumière c'était
donc l'interview le bec et voyez
quelimane il manie le ouzbeks
mamy blues bec à l'intersection voulait
qu'on tente une petite expérience sur ce
plateau
ça s'appelle opération barbichette lidar
[Applaudissements]
et
attention je te tiens tu me jette le
premier qui rira aura une taupe
le premier qui est rare à une [ __ ]
est-ce que roch voisine est prêt en
coulisses très bien attention on ne se
marre pas dire vous allez avoir une
[ __ ]
oh attention on n'a pas le droit de
faire ça tout le temps on se regarde
attention je compte 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
linde a perdu et oui c'est toi tu es à
pas-de-calais 1 quel choc est alors
c'est un baiser ou une [ __ ] qu'est ce
que vous préférez
ah c'est toi qui choisis moi qui ai
choisi annoncé ou faire don de donner
une [ __ ] ou moi je fais un bisou
bah je vais tout à fait à une [ __ ]
avec mes lèvres
merci binda je trouve que vous êtes mais
bien réussi à bien réussi cette
opération j'ai pas réussi
vous n'êtes pas réussi mais enfin si
vous voulez il ya eu un grand moment
d'émotion parce qu'il ya un grand moment
d'émotion sur le plateau tout le monde
l'a bien ressenti avec moi alors
maintenant on vous restez avec nous
ouais si c'est beau non mais non j'en
sais rien jour là qu'est ce qui est
prévu c'est que vous réussirez pas
d'accord vous restez là il va partir
mais c'est la vérité parmi eux avec des
jeux d'eau avaient été parmi les
premiers comics a vraiment joué avec
avec vos origines en entendre h 45 les
[ __ ] ont fait le boulot c'est assez
violent
il ya un sketch dans la cassette évier
semoun consacré aux pompes funèbres
c'est un incinérateur et vous dites
c'est de la bonne machine c'est de la
marque allemande un calmant devez vous
allez enlever ça dans le spectacle je
n'ai pas enlevé mais c'est vrai que de
temps en temps
j'étais obligée d'aller m'expliquer
auprès de la communauté juive pour dire
que déjà que j'étais juif ce qui s'avère
aider et que bon c'était pour moi une
façon de dénoncer une certaine période
quoi mais que c'était pas la peine de
prendre ça au premier degré parce qu'il
ya des gens qui a été choqué ce que je
comprends à mon but c'est pas d'être de
faire du mal aux gens non mais vous avez
quand même déclaré dans six ou sept love
ça c'est violent quand même il n'y a pas
assez de gens d'obédience judaïque à la
télévision une sauce man
nous ne sommes pas assez représentées
c'est fera passer de l'amour ça passe
est vrai qu'aujourd'hui avec les juifs
qui provoquait des juifs bas j'aurais
tendance à dire oui mais
c'est aussi c'est peut-être grâce à
l'envers quoi je suis pas ouais j'aurais
tendance à dire oui j'ai un goal dit ça
il est viré le lendemain matin
ouais je pense vous avez fêté yom
kippour non j'avoue que je suis un chien
mauvais juif je ne suis juif qu'en
dessous de la ceinture et quelque chose
là non non non mais toujours casse toi
puis ça fait un truc
ah ouais elle elle veut que je me casse
ouais est ce qu'elles peuvent venir ici
pour me le dire
est ce que c'est possible parce que
j'aimerais inadmissible qu'on invite des
gens dans des émissions de télévision et
que les personnes se soient obligés de
se casser non mais au cul ouais je me
casse mois
oh pardon non l'aller
à tous les trois mois je veux bien
continuer tous les autres à 100 d'accord
ou qu'après trois ans je suis quasiment
[Applaudissements]
bomba qu'est ce que tu fais partie d'une
équipe sur un magnéto de l'un de vos
sketches griffi d'accord très bien c'est
quand même moi je me sens mieux sans
ardisson c'est bien tous les deux
finalement ça donne envie de faire
l'émission en tout cas ça donne envie de
faire et si on donne envie peut-être que
je vais la faire jose maria chira vivien
il ya jospin qui veut venir maintenant
un nom magique chirac l'un bon alors il
cymbales chirac on lui donne une bière
d'ici là sa bière bien alors maintenant
mes enfants on va faire un petit peu de
promotion
continuer est mignonne
bon alors le spectacle donc elie semoun
alors je donne les dates maintenant
parce qu'il n'ya pas que les paris simon
gagné l'émission un signe alors le 28
mars à marseille le 5 avril à clermont
ferrand le 7 8 et 9 avril au casino de
paris 1 paris et le 13 avril à lyon
exact alors vous fait salle comble
partout c'est pour ça que je voulais pas
ce qu'il vaut mieux acheter les loyers
c'est vrai tu vois on est assis par
terre c'est pas dénoncé dans une
cassette aussi donc que je monte alors
c'est le spectacle elie semoun qui est
mise en scène par muriel robin et donc
comme elie vous l'a dit tout à l'heure
il faut vraiment y aller parce qu'après
il va faire un nouveau spectacle en
après je vais faire les petites annonces
voilà alors les gens après le spectacle
des fois viennent vous voir et vous dise
il ya des trucs des fois qu'ils sont un
peu durs quoi et vous faites des petits
ajustements ça vous arrive oui enfin dix
ans en belgique j'ai essayé de faire le
rigolo ça n'a pas fonctionné
le virer toutes les vannes non j'ai
parce que j'ai un sketch je fais une
sorte de vieux beau et qui se tape une
petite fille jeune fille etc puis à un
moment je fais ou et non pas la petit
jeu les rencontrer chez jean mimi chant
michel n'ont pas l'attitude petite halle
à 14 ans on n'est pas en belgique
donc oui c'est que là bas quand même si
parfois on essayait sont assez graves
là-bas vrai nom vous dit on peut rire de
tout mais est-ce qu'on peut le faire
tous les jours avec tout le monde en
fait c'est ça la vraie question
d'obliger devrait il ya souvent des gens
qui prennent les choses au premier degré
n'ont pas vous est jamais arrivé ce qui
est arrivé à timsit n'ont pas encore
activement du travail
oui mais ça c'est un vrai accident de
tracer un accident du travail qu'ils ils
l'ont confondu avec ils sont trompés de
cible c'est un comique mais ça colle
donc enfin je pense je vois si les gens
savent que ces gaccio qu'avait écrit le
corps encore lui vous êtes toujours en
tournée quoi pas non mais là ça se
termine
vous pouvez venir à votre femme que
c'est fini fini chérie je rentre à la
maison et alors quand vous rentrez chez
vous vous retrouvez vos serre parce que
ce que vous ne savez pas d'amuser les
spectateurs c'est que il y fait pousser
il fait pousser dans des serres écoute
si tu m'a invité à cette émission pour
te [ __ ] de ma gueule parce que je
chéris van dyck l'amour des plantes
tropicales voilà oui c'est des plantes
tropicales la marijuana vous appelez à
prendre là qui se fume mais bon alors
désormais donc vous travaillez sans la
personne de couleur qui vous
accompagnait avant et ça se passe plutôt
bien
ça se passe plutôt bien contre jamais
laird ancien vous avez un super épanouie
ça fait longtemps que je sois vu comme
ça la pêche c'est vrai un bail la
personne
me frapper ah bon et 1,9 hockey et ça je
n'ai jamais né en italie
je me suis vu au nom
c'est un rapport assez par rapport à
maeva ça vous embête au niveau de la
taille qua non la signature très
longtemps je te dépasse un petit peu
pour ça on sera ta gueule tu attends
mais alors tu vas toi tu joues tu veux
qu'on peut le moins cher est honnête
avec toi mais on a des photos et les
noms je veux dire c'est pas dit bonjour
je vais m'y attends brasse et voilà
moi
et c'est moi ayasse plus plus bien alors
j'ai laissé ça va vous êtes bien là j'ai
très bien vous me regardez moi dans les
yeux pas de ce fait comme si la personne
n'existe hélas personne n'existe pas
c'est peut-être ça n'existe pas c'est un
petit peu difficile bien enfin alors
combien de fois on vous dit que vous
êtes mignonne et tous ne dis jamais
jamais nous on dit aussi que familial
non ma rivale est pas mignon de maréval
belle mareva voit la belle femme belle
femme c'est une belle femme cette
journée une famille à elie semoun
oui parce que c'est vous gros succès
avec votre premier one man show elie
semoun mise en scène par votre amie
muriel robin avec le temps j'ai rien à
dire les qui vous étiez dans les
baladins de la jeunesse du toujours
sonné c'était insulte non sérieusement
c'était un énorme succès ce oui c'est
vrai ouais
oui c'est vrai que ça car c'est vrai un
message très fort et d'équité dieudonné
ouais moi j'y croyais mais il ya des
gens et vous le premier qui sait comment
ça va se passer
et en fait ça marche encore mieux
qu'avec deux oui c'est vrai bien que je
regrette de plus être avec lui c'était
sympa mais bon c'est vrai que ça marche
vous et ça marche bien c'est vrai faut
le dire alors actuellement
à l'affiché un film qui s'appelle
deuxième vie oui d'un film de patrick
braoudé avec gad elmaleh thierry
lhermitte
voilà vous allez prendre le cours de
proment à la télé brücker qui est encore
sur l'écran un sim que l'on peut aller
voir dans toutes les salles de cinéma
moyennant une s'il te plait je suis
parti sur ma lancée une somme de 40
francs film où l'on rigole film où l'on
s'esclaffe film où l'on l'eau frémit des
cinémas complet voilà mais voilà ça
c'est de la promenade prenez-en de la
graine
voilà c'est un film de patrick braoudé
qu'isabelle deuxième vie c'est
l'histoire d'un garçon qui s'appelle
vincent qui a 30 ans qui est incapable
de choisir dans la vie ce qu'il veut
faire
et un jour il ya un accident de voiture
et il se retrouve le destin choisi à sa
place ils se retrouvent pdg odieux avec
ses amis etc
j'étais un film qui se marrent jeunes
idées ses traits à l'australie qui va
être achetée pas américain sûrement
sûrement et puis
areva
voilà ça s'appelle elie annoncé mon nom
ça c'est le dvd c'est pour les riches il
faut déjà se payer le lecteur ça c'est
pour nous c'est à dire à ce qu'aucun
magnétoscope voilà c'est la cassette qui
a comme star jahjaga d'iliad jamais n'y
d'armes au il ya cristiana reali il ya
les robail à franck dubosc évidemment
il ya plein de gens n'y a pas qu'à des
oliviers et areva il n'ya pas hors du
champ des vite douillet etc
vous êtes prêts oui on va faire une
interview sans intérêt dans la bouche
bush pendant la guerre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
génial dès que ma fille est partie il ya
quand même beaucoup moins de bachir est
vrai dix mois elle a rappelé la meuf là
non ah bon
sa part rappelé non non je comprends pas
d'ailleurs pourquoi pas ce que je vais
pas fidèlement numéro un
peut-être qu'on a parfois way et cet été
à la mer ou à la montagne pas jeter à la
mer mais ouais c'était moi ya pas
tellement d'autres 2-1 trop de chance
sur le trop de sable trop de j'aime pas
ouais ouais ouais t'as pas fait pas dix
balles pour le cas d'yves non je fais
rentrer du fioul ouais j'ai fait rentrer
du chemin j'en ai suffisamment pour le
mois de décembre mais un moment que pour
janvier
normalement on est sur le coup de tête
il y avait aussi un cousin qui va passer
pour andré bonnet ça va de soi
je fais tout le monde en parle la
voiture allait fermer
justement j'ai mon arme qui marchent
plus je ne suis pas allée où je me suis
foutu au parquet à moi ça va alors il ya
un gardien tu as toi sinon ça va moins
ça va je fais tout le monde en parle oui
oui ça va t'as pas vu ma personne non je
la trouve plus ça se passe bien toi moi
c'est vrai tu fais quoi en ce moment
tout le monde en parle ah ouais d'accord
mais tu y croies ce truc toi non pas
trop c'est pas ses parents comme ça il
ya quelque chose qui me dérange d'entrée
moi aussi je fais pas un pardon non télé
poche
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours demandé si tu aimais des
chiens moi je me suis posé la même
question hier tu étais j'ai glissé sur
un truc et puis je me suis dit que
j'aimais pas les chiens ça va tu as et
je passe bien je suis toujours dans papa
oui bien sûr que tu en penses que ça
s'organise bien ta chemise la tullaye au
jeu les acheter chez d'infliger
chemisier médias chemisier ben je me
suis dit que bon il soit d un petit peu
pour la scène
ça va je me sens un petit peu crispé tu
vois mais ça ne tient pas chaud ça a pas
trop le pas trop chaud en même temps il
fait chaud ici
ouais je connais la chemise de seine
ouais ça se passe bien je fais tout le
monde en parle moi tu vois ça s'organise
c'est vrai ça va ça marche bien méchant
qui met un climat qui n'est pas
longtemps pour les questions non mais je
sais pas pour les fêtes tu fais quoi
alors pour les fêtes par exemple noël
ouais et je vais probablement acheté un
sapin
chacun est maintenant et zemun
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est
alors oui c'est très étonnant c'est que
vous êtes un habitué des plateaux de
télévision
relativement souvent c'est d'ailleurs
moi aussi moi je suis pratiquement tous
les jours et pourtant vous êtes parfois
mal à l'aise et vous avez déclaré
j'aimerais pouvoir parler de mon travail
sans être coincé entre deux rubriques à
la con sans passer après un sujet sur
les nouveaux slip en hollande
oui bon c'est vrai que c'est pas
toujours c'est pas très valorisant
d'être d'être à terre par exemple de
vingt animateurs
oui je me considère comme un artiste je
fais un certain travail
j'estime que être comme ça à plat ventre
devant les sur les plateaux de télé
c'est pas mon style d'accord mais
j'estime que j'ai une certaine fierté
bien sûr mais jamais au grand jamais je
me mettre à genoux devant toi par
exemple en importance à la je suis un
artiste que j'espère de talent enfin en
tout cas c'est ce que les gens ne me
renvoie que nous l'envisagions rien
quand même
c'est pour ça donc elie semoun ce soir
on va parler de votre travail
on va parler des slips en parler de
votre travail on va parler de la génèse
de votre acte aura elie semoun
[Applaudissements]
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette
petit ami de bien vous brosser les dents
effet tout bourré donc à 10 ans elie
semoun vous écriviez déjà de deux petits
poèmes veut mettre un peu plus à l'aise
mais faites ce que vous voulez a du mal
à me sentir à l'aise dans cette émission
jégo sur la table voilà là comme ça je
me sens mieux vas-y toi là par le moins
très bien comment ça va ça va comment ce
que j'étais toujours j'étais un peu
crispé au départ oui et comme j'avais eu
des problèmes en famille familialement
j'ai toujours voulu exprimer d'une façon
théâtrale chose que je ce que je voulais
dire c'est à dire pour moi là je t'aime
pour moi là la réalité a toujours été
difficile à comprendre mais
l'homosexualité par contre j'aime bien
écouter
ce soir on a décidé c'est ta soirée ces
masques on va parler de ton travail
comme ça et surtout chez à temps parce
que je me sens pas à l'aise là je m
comme ça j'ai l'impression d'être
l'athlète du mois c'est un joli cul
ouais bien c'est donc elie semoun on va
parler de la génèse de votre acte au
racing allait bien puisque si si c'est
une émission culturelle donc à 10 ans
vous écriviez déjà de petits poèmes
oui j'étais déjà temps je vais me mettre
à l'aise gt gt déjà en effet attiré par
tout ce qui était positif ce qui était
un petit stick c'était jeu j'avais le
désir déjà des train d'être un artiste
est ce qu'on pourrait dire qu'à l'époque
vous étiez elie semoun un artiste en
miniature oui j'étais un mini artistes
mais aussi bien physiquement que
qu'intellectuellement non mais c'est
vrai je tombais amoureuse régulièrement
j'étais tombé amoureux de ma prof de
français et ce n'est absolument pas
marché j'avais 11 ans et qu'elle devait
avoir à peu près 40 ans j'avais écrit
des poèmes
elie semoun à 15 ans vous étiez déjà sur
scène et ça me permettait en fait comme
je branlée pas grand faim je faisais pas
grand chose on peut dire branlée ici je
suis oui oui oui je pense avec toi donc
je ne foutais pas grand chose mais
j'avais cette excuse auprès des profs
d'être un petit peu artiste donc il me
passait un peu les des choses quoi moi
là il a 19 ans à 19 ans elie semoun
vous rejoignez la troupe de roger louret
les balades ramage mais vous rencontrer
la suite on la connaît on la connaît
tous les toutes les
tous les médias savent un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé avec la personne de
couleur tout à fait suite on la connaît
cela soit vraiment non avant je voulais
qu'on connait vraiment face à face comme
ça mais je voudrais qu'on fasse tous les
deux une expérience de télépathie oui je
vais te poser une question si chic mans
oui et tu va me répondre
attention voilà jamais à bord n'ont
jamais aussi bon mais avec une fille oui
[Applaudissements]
alors on sent en sentant incroyablement
bien c'est faux moi je vais dire quelque
chose d'aussi way 23 a quand même dans
la journée non le soliste bien alors là
on a parlé de roger louret donc les
baladins en agenais muriel robin tout ça
les débuts et l'ours qui est incroyable
c'est que aujourd'hui vous travaillez
toujours avec roger louret vous êtes
d'une incroyable fidélité suis fidèle
amitié c'est pas mal quand même comme
sentiment voulez vous dire quelque chose
à roger louret je crois que c'est
important pour vous ce soir de lui celui
des rochers
je sais que tu ne regardera pas cette
émission non mais si jamais il ya des
gens des amis à toi qui regardent cette
émission où toi même je voudrais dire je
crois que l'ag
j'ai un gros plan je voudrais dire que
je t'apprécie énormément en tant qu'être
humain et que tu m'as apporté tout ce
dont tout ce dont je rêvais hormis
évidemment ce que tu sais elie semoun
vous avez repris en octobre votre
tournée avec votre dernier spectacle est
d'ailleurs vous êtes demain à marseille
le 27 à arcachon le 2 décembre à créteil
le 3 à issy les moulineaux le six à
poitiers et le 16 au bataclan
c'est très important parce que c'est une
soirée au profit de solidarité sida
c'est complet déjà donc je vous remercie
les gens qui ont acheté leurs places ils
vont faire une bonne action et on sait
en effet les excuser moi je suis un
petit peu ému une façon pour moi
d'évacuer un petit peu j'étais très mal
c'est bien alors ce spectacle a été
captée à l'olympia en juin
j'avais pas faire toi même et olympia
spectacle et bien sûr mais ça veut dire
en même temps alors on y retrouve toutes
vos obsessions elie semoun tous vos
personnages toufik tout fait originaire
de malgré tout toujours originaire de
maghrébine qui fait des qui fait un
questionnaire de sondages par vous
j'essaie de parler à deux mains fait
tout ça et de puits en a une qui veut
qu'il veut pas répondre il la traite
d'enculé lui des vases et pourquoi tu me
regardent comme ça et j'ai peu que tu
m'agresses comme ça enfin bref c'est
toujours un petit peu énervé toufik et
il ya kevin à 1 alors kevin asselin
classique moi je vous dis ma fille à
l'école
c'est tous les joueurs wii kevina c'est
devenu un personnage de la société
française vous à inventer quelque chose
et c'est une petite adolescente et qui
parle pendant des heures au téléphone
voilà copine je connaissais la vraie
vivre j'en ai deux à la maison
et alors jeanne calment vous a inspiré
un sketch
ouais paix à son âme d'ailleurs je crois
qu'elle est décédée
ah bon elle a mis du temps mais bon non
mais en fait oui c'est le g1 sketches au
début du spectacle c'est sur une maison
de retraite
ouais ça m'a été inspiré en voyant cette
magnifique émission qui s'appelle strip
tease bien sûr où il y avait un
reportage sur les vieux
et on voyait une infirmière qui n'a pas
mangé ce matin ou pas ça va gueuler
sociaux parce que moi je vous ramène
dans la chambre les petits prix sur une
chaise roulante
ah bon ça alors avec dubosc avec dubosc
que vous avez fait les petites annonces
away dans les petites annonces d'elie
semoun fait souvent la fille oui oui
vous aimez faire ma fille c'est une
proposition non c'est une interview
c'est l'interview victor victoria tu
t'appelles comment géraldine géraldine
juliette
j'ai deux prénoms chez un petit peu
intimidé par dont tu as quel âge et
réalville gérer 16 ans l'année prochaine
sera du mois géraldine est ce que ta
meilleure amie est grosse mais sympa
ouais j'ai une super amis en fait on est
hyper copine depuis le collège
je lui fais un petit coup derrière elle
et elle est grosse et les tranches ne le
sens pas un résultat savent pas c'est
que moi je l'appelle la femme série
super rapide accord était dingue dis-moi
géraldine tut après lycée winter moi je
n'aime pas les vieux tu veux dîner ou ce
soir je sais pas mcdo burger king
ah ouais super je sais pas j'aimerais
bien qu'on a et flunch et aux dix mois
sur la dig est ce que tu mets la longue
le premier soir c'est la tan
la deuxième ça
quelques averses dis moi tu sais combien
géraldine ouais bien sûr
oui
vim ouais parce que tu m'appeler
juliette juliette juliette
ouais est-ce que tu poseras un goal les
goys c'est ce qu'ils sont pas circoncis
ouais je sais pas j'ai jamais vu de sexe
donc je sais pas ce que ça donne rien
contre non j'ai rien contre chez ma
copine justement la grosse là alors
qu'on l'appelle aussi garage contre avec
lui on part tu demanderas dis moi tu as
fait quoi pour tes cheveux là bas je
commence à les pertes je comprends pas
j'ai 14 ans c'est bizarre juliette c'est
un train de partir en sucette tout ça
profites en ouais dis moi est ce que tu
pourrais tomber amoureuse d'un animateur
télé banon passieu parce que bon ben moi
j'estime
bon je suis bon j'ai rien compris
disons la communauté je dirais
pédéraste alizon bon moi je
personnellement j'ai jamais été attiré
par les hommes
un bonbon mais j'ai rien commente un jeu
n'est pas bon il ya quand même une
ouverture d'esprit et on en l'an 2000 il
ya quand même bon les moeurs ont évolué
mais qu'il préférait me tape à un mec
non avec tout le respect que je te dois
va te faire [ __ ]
j'ai envie tu veux des enfants
ouais j'aimerais bien chez terre des
enfants j'ai un petit frère qui a six en
revanche il adore que ouais kevin kevin
steen regarde coucou dis moi tu l'aies
mme nicole kidman à celle d'orge plus
c'est une super actrice
sans déconner je les ai vus dans bon là
c'est pas génial mais sans déconner mais
c'est super bon mais moins belle que
jennifer a bon hein
elle est bien des différences et des
caisses qu'ils sont bien en même temps
elles chantent dix mois au lit tarifs de
simuler des fois tu veux dire au lit
quand je suis tout seul oui mais je fais
semblant de dormir
géraldine est ce que tu porterait du
noir avec du bleu marine
non parce que ma couleur préférée c'est
droz ah ben ouais tout va bien le nuage
tout c'est hyper trice 3 pas ouais et
j'aimerais aussi je considère que la
guerre c'est pas bien ouais et que quand
j'ai toujours aimé les fleurs parce que
c'est hyper beau ça c'est comment
dirais-je
je suis pas j'ai envie de chialer alors
quoi c'est pas grave
géraldine tu regardes quoi en premier
chez un homme j'aurais tendance à dire
son cul mais comme ce qui gêne je
regarde piteux son regard porter le
regard c'est vrai je trouve que le
regard c'est la fenêtre de l'âne tu vas
sepa natasha st pier qui a dit ça c'est
vrai à 17h rens
c'est super ah ouais
est ce que tu es du genre à coucher le
deuxième soir géraldine non d'abord je
m'appelle pas dire a dit ça le fait
voilà c'est impressionnant et c'est
impressionnant
[Musique]
ces femmes là meurent là bas donc a levé
dès la vhs alors il ya un autre art et
lee ou ne doutant pas que vous êtes
scellier bientôt c'est le cinéma vous
vous prenez un tel plaisir à incarner
les personnages comme ça quand on vous
voit sur scène chez vous voir au
bataclan c'est formidable vivez les
personnages il faudrait que les
réalisateurs arrive à oublier ça vous
imaginez
c'est finalement c'est difficile
j'entendais il n'ya pas longtemps la
charlotte de turckheim a été invitée
chez marc-olivier chez enfin dans une
émission et qui disait c'est difficile
quand on a une forte personnalité
artistique que les les metteurs en scène
fantasme sur vous quoi c'est un peu
compliqué parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
se dire que on est comédien enfin vous
faudra un rôle comme coluche dans tchao
pantin oise oeuvre dans le rhin
d'amérique c'est un rôle sérieux en
rôles dramatiques
bah oui pourquoi pas un rôle alors pour
le moment effectivement choisit
systématiquement josé garcia bruno solo
ça vous ça vous emmène moi je trouve que
josé garcia brune seconds sont des
excellents comédiens et les bons amis et
je trouve que c'est vraiment mérité quoi
ya pas de problème mais j'ai pas de jets
pas de frustration j'ai une petite
frustration mais j'ai pas d'aigreur
je suis pas la rue quoi enfin ça va quoi
je travaille bien général les salles
sont pleines et où tout va bien
simplement c'est vrai que j'aimerais
réussir dans ce domaine là moi je crois
que moi je crois que vous exposeriez
dans le rôle d'un petit truand très
méchant oui dans une petite taille
exacte one petit salé c'est vrai une
petite salle intime qu'il faut pas lui
tourner donc pas ce que c'est et c'est
vite parti voilà c'est ça mais
l'assurance à un petit coup sûr alors
dans votre dvd lycée moon à l'olympia il
ya un bonus en deux parties alors le
première partie ces trois villes en
province
m montpellier gex ouais donc on vous
voit en tournée signer des autographes
dans la voiture vous n'avez pas de
chauffeur
non non j'aime bien conduire je dise
j'aime bien conduire ça vous choquerait
d'avoir un chauffeur
ouais j'aime pas trop l'idée d'être
servi par quelqu'un je n'aime pas ça
mais je le dis d'ailleurs même quand je
prends un taxi
ça me gêne pour le mec non mais non mais
chez pour me faire masser non mais ça me
gêne quand je vais dans un de thalasso
tout ça
j'ai besoin il faut que je parle à ma
fille naturellement que je fasse l'amour
avec elle
donc ça c'est la 1ère partie la deuxième
partie ça s'appelle les yeux dans semoun
et on voit votre votre premier soir à
l'olympia à paris avec la visite de
lionel jospin et de sylviane mesdames
messieurs magnéto serge
[Musique]
on était très content j'ai un peu ses
huit en poche qu'on peut faire le saut
c'est un peu qu'ils comptent bien sûr
que je crie après revient pas trop drôle
oui il n'y a jamais été aussi écroulé
que d'abandonner les flops
est-ce que vous allez là non crème un
truc là et où j'étais l'enfant ce schéma
sur ces trucs là tout est un sketch où
il est dit tu veux que je rentre et que
je pète dont boris et ça fait même temps
une double dans le bourg ses fins
d'affaires et ceci vous allez bien sacha
bon mais tout le monde a été touché et
est lâchement et non pas moi c'est
l'autre
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils aient un
sens et c'est ce qui fait le plus vil le
mec je sais pas c'est la dame pipi
canton des flaques quand j'en mets c'est
insensé mais d'ailleurs je voudrais le
remercier d'avoir accepté d'être dans le
besoin à ce que je les appelais quand
même pour lui demander parce que il est
venu me voir c'était je suis pas un mois
après sa défaite un peu moins que ça ait
un donc je lui ai dit est ce que vous
acceptez d'être dans le bonus il m'a dit
mais oui comme vous m'avez soutenu pour
ma campagne
barrot d'ailleurs je vais vous dire
voilà enfin il est moi j'aime bien je
trouve
je sais vous avez déclaré jospin il a su
partir avec panache
mais bon vous pensez sérieusement qu'il
est parti avec la nage du parti
s'enliser l'adage avec panache et on va
dire ça comme ça au sujet de lionel
jospin vous avez déclaré lionel merci
d'avoir travaillé pour la france avec
autant de droiture et d'honnêteté et
j'espère le temps ironique que tim parks
traduction et j'espère lionel pour vous
que votre future vie d'homme pas
politiques soient aussi brillante que
votre vie d'homme politique
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai moi j'aime bien les mecs comme
ça c'est l'être humain qui me plaît cela
vous pensez que jospin laissera dans
l'histoire le souvenir d'un mendès
france u20 léon blum
c'est à dire des talents gâchés ouais je
pense mais heureusement il reste delanoë
votre ami de dano et comment il va
bailly va mieux mais jamais un peu
fatigué mais c'est normal on t'aurait
foot et un couteau dans le ventre en
temps ça va avec je donne hélas oui ça
va ouais ouais
voici dieudonné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'était une blague
[Musique]
pas la moindre
donc voilà je te dirai non c'est le dieu
de célébrer diallo mais ce soir il est
venu sans djellaba quoi c'est vrai je
voulais venir avec une kippa
je commence par gedo qui commence l
charrier sur l'équipage jamais en sortir
bon alors je suis très heureux de vous
voir tous les deux si longtemps bah oui
je suis content du temps avec ton petit
regard là que j'aime le bien que tu me
faisais pareil tu sais que tu vas me
faire pleurer oui moi je le sais bon
comment ça va tous les deux alors on va
faire c'est mon choix maintenant comment
ça va bah disons chez j'ai vécu des
choses des choses fait des choses pas
évident ok alors qu'on était lui moins
on était comme deux doigts de la main
grâce au tir ardisson le chien a été
retrouvé que j'ai vécu des choses
extraordinaires
et que je te
avant ça
la seule question que j'ai ouï en
agacera saga parler des choux la seule
question tu as toujours pas creps est ce
que vous voyez des fois c'est vu ouais
exceptionnellement bas c'est moi qui ai
un petit peu brisé la glace coin qui ai
téléphoné et j'ai été bon quoi j'ai été
un peu reclus j'ai fait la campagne
aussi jeu tout à fait sûr la capitale
noté
non parce qu'à l'époque où je déconne il
l'était en grottes les terrains cavernes
et je pense que tu te rends mon nom
c'est téléphoné parce que je me suis dit
que commence envoyer un petit peu d'aidé
vannes médiatiquement un par média
interposé je me suis dit que c'était
dommage quoi il ya quand même une amitié
il ya quand même c'est andy commune
il ya eu beaucoup de grands spectacles
ensemble beaucoup de bombay où il avait
fait passer c'est que systématiquement
les gens qui viennent me voir avec qui
je parle après spectacle il n'y a pas un
jour où on ne dit pas alors quoi avec la
multiple a enfin bon il ya des gens ont
vraiment des références du duo quoi j'ai
proposé à lévis tout à l'air de faire un
duo avec dubosc
il n'a pas voulu tu vois j'ai dit oui
oui j'étais complément de sa personne
avec qui je pourrais revenir en voilà
ces sept personnes
enfin après qu'on lit évidemment fait
tout pour attirer toute la partie du
cervelas
toute la partie politique là que vous
voyez ici quand y provoque à ce
moment-là et l'antisémitisme qui est
alors sérieusement moi je
j'ai encore a conduit une interview par
téléphone tout à l'heure légale
non mais j'ai déjà ya là bas je te
laisse moi de parler jeu des bombes et
je sais des choses essentielles dans ton
sport c'est vrai que j'aime chez ce que
j'aime chez cette personne c'est
l'artiste c'est vrai que bon tu as été
un petit peu loin de temps en temps tu
reconnais moi j'ai toujours mal quand je
n'étais pas bon seulement je te fixes et
j'ai pas peur de ce que j'essaye de bain
mais bon ça évidemment gagner ya des
hauts et des bas comme partout par
contre moi je n'ai jamais fait qu'il y
ait des tests la population noire ne m'a
jamais heurter par ces morts bon ça
c'est un fait qui était je suis
contrarié ensemble et val du côté qu on
se lançait c'est vrai que c'est amusant
que finalement avec le temps les choses
sont statines pas ça fait partie du jeu
est un peu fort temps en temps dans
l'attaqué tout ce que je fais ce que je
veux pas répéter
non mais moi j'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir été loin un jeune humaniste mais
c'est vrai que je me batte choses qui
peuvent énerver la sensation
d'appartenir à une communauté
n'appartient à aucune autre communauté
que l'humanité je sais ce que j'ai dit
pour joindre que je peux répéter
oui aucune autre communauté que
l'humanité tu te disais je veux non même
si une différence entre les hommes et
les femmes tout le monde bouge c'est la
dernière frontière que je reçus en train
de remettre en cause ouais je fais un
peu de mal quand même ça qui les lie
réflexe c'est de faire un dessin
la différence entre un homme là tu as la
partie pour monet way
marielle je ne dis pas qu'il ya des
détails de la passion peut encore parler
de détails mais il faut que je fasse
attention
c'est vrai que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
et c'est super d'ailleurs on est dans
une période où entre l'homme et la femme
c'est un peu le sujet d'ailleurs de mon
spectacle mais
la frontière est de plus en plus plus en
plus étroite et puis un jour elle espère
être rien et l'humain avant toute chose
qui me paraît indispensable
vous en voulez tous les deux ou non non
non mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai un
rapport affectif avec les gens et j'en
avais un très fort avec dieu dos et il
ya certaines choses qui m'ont je me suis
sentie trahie quoi donc pour moi ça a
été c'était difficile de cette
séparation mais pour lui aussi le montre
pas mais bon voilà quoi
alors que j'ai chialé je me suis mis à
chercher chez moi mais tu voulais
construire voix non mais on est les
mêmes si je voulais voir mon spectacle
si vous allez voir le spectacle de
dieudo il ya des personnages qui sont
eux qui sont qui nous appartiennent et
puis qu'on a pris séparément
j'ai pas une façon de s'exprimer comme
s'il ya un petit peu la patte
elie et dieudonné est ce que je dirais
c'est à dire des personnages qui et qui
exprime des vérités mais qui sera en
même temps d'écouter bien dieudo va bien
tout cas on vous restez avec nous
dieudonné compris mais ce combat parce
qu'il est venu il n'ya pas longtemps
dieudo eskom a gardé la la bande annonce
de 200 spectacles divorce de patrick
lalala mandeure j'avais à faire des
trucs ensemble
bah on en a parlé
je sais je sais pas justement je ne t'ai
pas rappeler tu l'as remarqué que ceux
proposés lis que je te propose c'est que
je sais que tu participent au téléthon
avec axel est la marraine du téléthon
alors je vais vous faire une proposition
moi j'ai peut-être chalet pour une fois
et voilà et pourquoi vous feriez pas un
sketch où les deux juste pour faire
gagner de l'argent à des lettons basser
on ne peut pas refuser
oui moi je suis d'accord ah ouais bon
beskides il y a ouais c'est ça non là le
truc catherine la très bien je peux dire
mon truc là du le ton truc qu'on le
connaisse elie semoun ton truc
[Musique]
voilà excuse moi et me way s'est passé à
ces questions même ça fait trois fois
que je vais te dirai lynch est pas où
elle a la tête mais line en ce moment là
il morata méline attention mettez doigt
comme soi mais l'inattention bragance
[Rires]
[Musique]
2 vous vous voyez
pour moi
mais si elie semoun
[Musique]
moi je vais pirelli et michelin quand tu
rentres comme ça sur cette musique c'est
pas l'entrée est un peu pour rire ah
ouais parce que j'adore faire ce sont
ces gens sont là c'est vrai que pour une
entrée c'est moins forte que ces mots
didier
[Musique]
c'est une bonne chanson mais certaines
chansons entrées ouais bah ouais ouais
peut-être mais ça n'a pas empêché de
rentrer quand même ray zapping quand
vous avez décidé de faire ce disque tous
vos amis vos vos parents votre papa tout
le monde vous a dit ne le fait pas ce à
quoi tu vas tu ris mais oui c'est vrai
qu'on a on m'a déconseillé de le faire a
motivé ça m'a motivé loi non franchement
oui et non oui parce que c'est mais
c'est pas évident je m'en aperçois
encore maintenant de tu vois là j'ai
l'impression d'être multi cartes je
viens présenter un disque était après
les cassettes des petites annonces
passées
c'est vrai que c'est bizarre et je crois
que j'espère que les gens vont pas être
trop déstabilisés mais je crois qu'il
faut s'attendre les gens auxquels le
quota gueule c'est qu'on commence direct
je crois qu'on en a trente mille ou 30
nuit un truc comme ça
l'album c'est pareil c'est pas mal et
puis ensuite j'étais allé faire
l'appareil que vous un courage
absolument incroyable et est allé faire
la première partie de laurent voulzy
c'est pas évident parce que les gens
qu'on est arrivé sur scène surtout quand
on n'est pas chanteur
après un petit peu le système lorsque
j'indique et les gens s'attendaient à
rire non mais c'est vrai et comme
j'étais arrivé sur ce schéma qui faisait
un tir de la voix comme ça ah ouais
c'est un peu spécial c'est vrai je
déconnais entre les chansons pour
essayer de 2 que que les gens me
retrouve dans ce qui me choque dans ce
qu'ils connaissent deux mois mais mais
dès que j'ai commencé à chanter ça
allait tout le monde dormait je ne
devrais pas dire ça parce qu'il fait du
mal franchement c'est très loose avait
tenu bon alors vous disiez elie semoun
si ça marche pas j'en ferais pas un
deuxième alors quel est le verdict lé
verdict bas n'ont pour l'instant je ne
pense pas à faire un deuxième je pense
plutôt faire un nouveau spectacle mais
j'ai beaucoup de respect d'un seul coup
une rafale de ouf toi ça va vite et que
je regarde ton truc comme un vrai jeu
fait moyennement confiance bien alors
c'est que la chaîne france 2 a fait une
étude sur les invités de tokyo elie
semoun et vous êtes parmi les meilleurs
invités de talk-show les meilleurs
clients comme on dit vous êtes en tête
vous savez ça annonce avait pas vous
êtes encore être facile tous les shows
confondues en tête mais qu'il est le
meilleur client pour les spectateurs
c'est les gens qui disent ah ouais on
leur a demandé - jours pour vous quel
est le meilleur qui est le meilleur avis
et on à tokyo à la télé bon ça c'est
sympa et lycées c'est pas les mecs qui
souhaitent à pois qui montrent leur cul
ou qui cassent tout sur les places et où
le meilleur je comprends qu'on voit
souvent la télévision parce que
effectivement le meilleur ça va toi
sinon il fallait que je fasse une
réplique qu'il fallait que je
je remercie les gens question suivante
gérard duthy classé deuxième des
premiers l'année dernière pierre arditi
les passer deuxième c'était normal
aurélie on va pas les faire passer le
test on va lui donner une carte de bons
clients tout de suite en tête des
sondages à gilles carle de vampires
voilà merci c'est qu'avec cette carte
[Applaudissements]
le sondage il aérienne n'est même pas
tout le monde n'ont cessé depuis
longtemps que j'ai pas vu l'émission
donc je me suis fait avoir c'est ça non
je veux dire la vérité tu as tu ne t'y
crois pas mais pierre arditi il ya cru
j'ai dit voilà car dit-il un sondage qui
était fait par france 2 sur les bons
clients des tokyoïtes où vous êtes
numéro un tout autre chose at il dit
et puis c'est pour ça tout le monde
attendait que je réagisse gonfle un peu
super tirer quelque chose avec ses
cartes on dirait prénom
c'est nous chaque émission vous parlez
de dieudonné vous souvenez c'est
incroyable loki dieu n'en est qu'à une
époque
non mais c'est vrai un jour de dieudonné
je me souviens un jour je sortais des
chiraquiens et kinsale et uni à domicile
donc on va retrouver quand même j'ai
donné cinq minutes on va faire une
interview de données
alors elie semoun vous êtes je donnais
oui je suis sam à dieudo bas je dirais
nous les personnes de couleur
on n'a pas non mais j'aime pas me lancer
là dedans ce que je vais avoir un procès
john ans mais je suis dieu donnez donc
voile habitués à voir des procès ait
lieu de donner je suis lieu de dieu
d'accord je donnais ceci vous fait
bizarre de vous voir sans la barbe à la
télé ouais mais j'ai fait ça parce que
actuellement je suis sur un tournage de
film donc c'est pour ça que
10 on essaye de ressembler le plus
possible mon ancien collègue
elie semoun c'est pour ça donc je dois
interpréter le rôle d'un juif c'est pour
ça c'est pas facile
non c'est pas évident c'est pas évident
pour vous de jeux d'eau et je me suis
entraîné g ils ont ajouté des pièces de
monnaie puis je me suis jeté dessus donc
s'élancer
[Applaudissements]
dieudo vous avez écouté l'album solo
d'elie semoun à wels aux rossignols
rossignol chantant j'ai écouté ça non
mais c'est bien il dit il a raison de
faire ça parce que disons semaine agitée
dans un petit plus c'est sa carrière
quoi si je peux lui donner un coup de
pouce éventuellement le pouce et d'un
précipice
hélas deux personnages perdus du permis
vous connaissez kevina os à vars et vina
je suis content d'être là
est ce que vous vous épuisez le public
d'une à banon c'est à dire qu'en ce
moment je commence à devenir une femme
je compte mes poils dsk c'est que la
visière carrière solo que elie semoun
niveau de la carrière des on les lit
après pris une tangente qui ne me
ressemble pas dire qu il est vraiment
dans le commercial il fait des gros sel
ils vont énormément de cassettes alors
que moi j'ai préféré faire ça le
contraire
est ce que quand même ce qui nous
passait pas j'exagère parce que j'ai
fait le zénith ya pas longtemps il y
avait du monde
d'ailleurs il ya mon copain guy bedos
qui est monté sur scène et qui a un
petit peu insulté sur scène devant les
gens qu'est-ce qui va de l'osce il a dit
il est rentré sur scène il a dit
enfin bon moi je suis pas responsable
il a dit ouais il est pas là lycée monde
il est en train de chanter puis là il ya
quelqu'un qui a violé dans le public et
puis la durée du don d'un droit de se
moquer des juifs sans être antisémite et
c'est donc guy bedos c'est mon ami vieux
bureau via lui répondre là bon ben ok
réconcilier dieudonné voulu passer des
petits coups de fil de temps en temps on
s'appelle je les appelais pour son
anniversaire mais moi je les appelais
quand sa famille est décédé
non on s'appelle non mais on s'aime
beaucoup hein y'a pas de soucis alors
dieudo à des petites vannes comme ça
mais abaissé celle amitié haine l'amour
haine
j'avais pensé à faire un duo un truc un
peu des sketches ensemble ouais non il
faut maintenant je le sens pas j'ai
peut-être ne mette avec un chinois
dieudo aussi vrai que je vais faire une
tournée en israël pour votre prochain
spectacle
je vais prendre un mais je vais y aller
en casque avec un casque est ce que
lourdes
au fait vous avez un petit mot à dire à
elie au cas où il regardait l'émission
giovanelli
si tu regardes démission tu le sais
que je t'aime et
bon bah c'est sûr on a eu des rapports
un petit peu conflictuelle mais tu le
sais toi et moi c'est pour toujours
[Musique]
chanson mais l'a levée sur toulouse
il est fou
[Musique]
rien 9
jeudi
et maintenant tu as i phone d'immostat
[Musique]
bon cela en france bonsoir temps
[Applaudissements]
ok
non
[Musique]
alors vous êtes tous les deux à nouveau
réunis dans pour les fameuses petites
annonces ce sixième volume
elie semoun annonce la suite avec vous
deux alors il ya un casting absolument
incroyable de guest-stars ya arthur il
ya adriana karembeu axelle laffont dave
dany boon bernard montiel laurent voulzy
lorànt deutsch estelle lefébure et
julien clerc et on est loin des blondes
à forte poitrine en vitesse non mais
c'est vrai il ya un casting du diable
alors on va les regarde ça va mieux il
ya surtout nous donne ouais hein
bien sûr tout nous deux oui c'est comme
jacques chirac toi je suis à paris je
[Applaudissements]
suis allé lui la bernadette bois j'ai
catherine barba cicatrice est bon bien
donc un casting du diable sur ce truc
webo m mais dans les autres cas cette
eau si on avait plein de gens à chaque
fois il ya un paquet de gens qui veulent
tourner avec nous c'est parce que c'est
on se marre bien
c'est un boulot de se déguiser c'est
vrai que tous les copains nous n'ont
toujours pas quand est ce que je fais un
truc c'est marrant de venir mettre une
moustache ou ou une perruque on est tous
des gamins dont qui viennent une robe
oui non non bien sûr bien sûr alors
franck est dit on va tenter maintenant
une première à la télévision
l'interview ventriloque c'est la
première fois que ces tentes et elie tu
fais la voix de dubosc du buzz que tu
fais la voix d'elie donnez vous la main
et bien entendu vous appuyez sur la main
de votre partenaire quand il ouvre la
bouche vous êtes près voilà
attention didier
alors on va d'abord vérifier si ça
marche elie comment ça va ça va plutôt
pas mal enfin c'est à dire que ça
pourrait aller mieux mais c'est vrai
quand même beau mâle j'ai vraiment fort
et vous franck la forme
ah ben ça va moi disons qu'on est toute
une équipe
on est mais on aimerait bien être
plusieurs
je sais pas si vous comprenez bien ce
que je dis si si si oui franchement
franck dubosc vous le trouvez peau ou
drôles
robin je le trouve beau et drôle je
trouve tout à la fois c'est un être
extraordinaire
est ce que j étais pas plus drôle
finalement quand il veut c'est que
dieudo manison j'estime que
quand j'ai connu et lis ça a été déjà
une révélation pour moi je me suis
demandé qu'est ce qui fait avec cette
personne de couleur
elie vous préférez quoi chez franck là
sa carrure le dire c'est quand même un
gars qui est bien foutu c'est un homme
intelligent c'est un homme qui a de
l'avenir c'est quelqu'un que j'aime en
coup là ça commence à me faire chier de
parler autant que ça alors le venir vers
vous et vous formez vous préférez quoi
shelly moi ce que j'ai toujours aimé
chez lui c'est sa sensibilité
c'est sans talent et c'est son
intelligence j'ai remarqué une chose
extraordinaire chez lui les démasquer
des mois parce que la cause de la paix
j'ai toujours trouvé chez lee ce talent
inné et inhérents
et j'adore vos disques vous le savez
j'aime beaucoup vous la chanson 14
promotion comme par hasard est ce que
vous pouvez lire nous en faire un petit
bout a cappella au bas pour vous en bas
pour vous en faire un bond au map a dit
s'attendre à ces mois ci
il est fou
[Musique]
donc comme du buzz vous avez que vous
êtes le rêve de la haye - cinq ans de la
ménagère de moins de 50 ans chère à nos
amis de tf1 vous leur dites quoi aux
ménagères de moins de cinquante ans
quand vous les draguer dans les
supermarchés franck gilard dit que les
emmerdes vie lequel de vous fera un bon
film en premier et moi tu vas parler
aussi des attentions
eri lequel de vous fera un bon film en
premier ben je crois que tu attendais
compris sa blague à la cour franck
lequel ne vous donne pas un bon film en
premier c'est évident que c'est moi
tranquille
cette chaude pisse s'est passé non c'est
pas encore passé j'ai encore des soucis
j'ai été opéré la semaine dernière on a
angers
la moitié de mes parties génitales c'est
pour ça que ils ont le rôle que
j'interprète en général de playboy est
complètement sûr fait j'ai d'accord avec
ça et lee quand vous pensez ça non non
c'est moi qui
l'intérieur entre rock
[Applaudissements]
ça
c'est ce que je viens longtemps il ya
une demi heure
ouais je sors du spectacle paris
justement prêté au théâtre du gymnase là
c'est ça au théâtre du gymnase où elie
semoun l'interprète elie semoun se prend
pour qui
dans une mise en scène de roger louret
coécrit par muriel robin tout à fait
merci au revoir
non c'est pas fini non non c'est pas
fini tabassé deux heures par jour
pendant combien de temps dans la cuisine
de mieux à leur bac
on a écrit on a mis je sais pas 5 6 mois
écrire ce spectacle douze heures pensé
qu'ils y six mois dans la cuisine a mûri
j'ai pas pris un qu'ils veulent c'est
elle qui les a pris des kilos en sans
commentaire oui on a écrit dans sa
cuisine tu que c'est un lieu symbolique
si tu connais la genette mais je suis
sorti avec elle pendant six mois
impressionnant les mecs qui raconte des
histoires comme ça jean ba voila j'ai
été violée à quatre ans après j'ai vécu
avec des loups pendant cinq ans lâche
sort de prison j'ai été pendant cinq ans
je suis poursuivi par des mecs qui
veulent me tuer je vais dire la vérité
même si je meurs demain
j'avais demain benko ils vont tripler
leurs droits est-ce que tu savais toi
qui avait des hommes politiques qui
faisait braquer des banques puissent
aller ça toi non moi je pensais que
c'était des gens honnêtes c'est pas ça
je suis surpris je pensais qu'il était
honnête quand on était au pouvoir on
était toujours correct chez stone &
savoir comment parler de salim
pourquoi il vous a parlé anglais vous
êtes anglais ce nom ah oui choqué
c'était génial tu es là c'est la vraie
rosbif quoi elle est rousse est tout à
la fois l'appareil dentaire bien plus
ment on est en france on parle de ton
spectacle
ouais mais tu veux pour preuve que son
boss - bah ouais ouais l'église la
galerie de portraits tout à fait correct
ok affirmatif
exact kevin na waie il ya julien toufik
way plus un vieux plus un récit jusqu'à
nos maux hystérique
oui tous des monstres quand même c'est
tous des monstres précisément pas vrai
c'est au fond c'est assez pathétique
c'est drôle mais c'est mais plus et noir
et plus c'est pathétique plus and play
c'est un suspect très bien mais je vois
laurent oui beaucoup
d'accord et je n'aime rien oui en plus
sûr mais quand moi j'ai plein de
collègues qui sont venus me voir et on
se demande toujours quand il ya des gens
enfin ils analysent tous wydad comment
il a trouvé 7,20 à côté de dioïla pas
rigoler du tout tu l'as vu dans le noir
alors il ya un truc surtout qui est
nouveau ouais c'est que tu fais
maintenant du stand up sur tu t'es tu
parles avec le public je me lâche un peu
c'est la grande nouveauté quand même ça
ce que j'avais l'habitude de me cacher
derrière des cachets je me cachais un
peu derrière des personnages et
maintenant je me lâche un peu le public
me fait un peu moins peur et je parle
avec ouais ouais mais ça c'est bien
c'est un mélange vient saluer à la fin
c'est nouveau ça non mais c'est vrai que
j'ai un problème
probablement de relationnel avec lequel
tu déteste les gens non mais de
peut-être un peu de timidité c'est
paradoxal mais c'est bizarre mais son
chanteur dima mais les applaudissements
il a fallu que mon metteur en scène me
dise comment faire comment revenir
saluer et c'est ce que j'ai toujours un
problème
je te jure elle est en train
le toit je vais vu moi elle me regarde
plus elle a du goût c'est tout je ne
regarde plus du tout moi j'existe plus
là d'un coup un adepte existe animaux
car ça c'est de la merde ou et sam chit
[Rires]
non mais ça marche bien spectacle
question qu'on dise c'est plein mois
quand j'y suis allé c'était c'est en
fait je fais de la promo juste pour le
plaisir de venir ici je suis content
mais c'est elle aime beaucoup les
français oui pas mal continue des
caméras tu as un pouvoir comique c'est
ça qu'il ya un pouvoir de séduction
ce qu'on appelle des funny bonne c'est
en anglais fanny bones les au comité
police ka-sat voilà et lui lui moi
moi j'y viens truc doit être payée ya un
truc grave bien il faut la haye celle
qu'on sache enfin quelque chose de
gentil comme quoi bon alors tu parles de
dieudonné évidemment dans ton spectacle
mais ça on s'y attend un peu en vacances
c'est un truc quand même c'est qu'au
début de votre association c'était cette
étoile pas trop en fait c'était moi le
patron oui quand on a commencé oui c'est
décidé je suis si non il voulait pas il
vendait des bagnoles enfin il est vrai
très bons comédiens en plus il n'était
pas feinte oui au début ils n'étaient
pas très bons comédiens mais il est
malin il a pris vie intelligente pour
moi c'est un très bon très très bon et
en fait vous avez pris un producteur il
a regardé comment ça se passe et après
j'ai appris d'eux faisait passer exact
rooney s'était lui était encore tarnac
airs juifs dieudonné est très fort
ensuite il a voulu vous produisiez vous
même est toujours là et c'est toi qui à
l'origine de son grief contre les jeux
ça c'est à cause de moi qu'il est
antisémite également résultat tu dis il
est devenu plus requins que les requins
c'est vrai qu'il a rapport avec l'argent
très spécial quoi toujours cette
paranoïa persistante la peur de se faire
avoir
voilà donc c'était son obsession il
fallait qui fonde sa société qui soit
son propre patron qu'il ait aucun qui
reçoivent aucun ordre etc
c'est son obsession il ya un truc là
même qui est marrant c'est quand vous
être vu à montréal l'été dernier dans ta
loge tu dis j'ai eu le sentiment que
tout ça n'était pas sérieux qu'il est
dans la provocation et que ça n'avait eu
six ans même toi tu arrives pas à croire
complètement à ce qu'il raconte quoi tu
penses qu'il fait ça pour faire chier il
ya des moments où ça me fait peur quand
je l'entends dire des conneries sur le
soi-disant lobby juif etc
et puis parfois je me dis que qu'il est
peut-être en train encore de jouer la
comédie
ça me trouble beaucoup que vont me
regarder comme ça
regarder les oiseaux je regarde plus
qu'à regarder non oui donc voilà non
voilà donc c'est peut-être effectivement
encore récession peut-être que c'est un
jeune étudiant cela on peut pas être son
excuse perpétuelle donc à un moment il
faut qu'il rende des comptes quoi moi il
a fait ici d'ailleurs est ce que tu es
d'accord pour faire une interview mu
mais oui mais j'ai joué dans des films
pour humaine mais j'ai bien l'intention
de tourner avec cédric klapisch
je ne travaille pas pour l'argent mais
mais en tant que personnes d'obédience
judaïque je suis intéressé par tout ce
qu'elle a tout l'aspect financier
évidemment je peux aller trop d'impôts
mais mais plus on en gagne plus on en
parle
voilà je ne crois pas en dieu mais mais
quand même j'aimerais bien qu'ils
croient en moi je vérifierai elle
réagissait sur je paye trop dormi c'est
sympa
sur l'intérieur d'un autre mec
vous avez pas en prison
je je je ici je me précipite pas
particulièrement les partouzes mais à
mai mais je ferais bien un petit tour au
bristol
je suis une star chez les gays mais tu
ne saches et léguer moi bien sûr
c'est vrai vous aime bien mais à choisir
je préfère prendre une janet je peux te
faire chier avec toute la communauté là
tu crois que il fait que j'avoue que
j'aimerais bien me faire attraper
éventuellement s'arrangeant était à
faire ça élargit vraiment ici
je ne suis pas jaloux mais mais quand
même ça m'ennuierait de savoir que tu as
un mec amaizing parce que j'ai un mec
d'antoine soir tentant l'ace l'est the
mystery of the better the mystery of
course
ok ok bonus ils apprennent single ce
soir une bonne je ne suis pas de droite
mais mais je suis de gauche j'ai une
toute petite [ __ ] mais bon c'est un jeu
et visages et je me sens les jeunes par
rapport à wendake y avait ce mot le dic
d'autres batailles plus de bristol le
big brain wolf sa paire de la bac s
commence à s'allonger s'éloigne
s'allonge je dors arthur mai mais j'aime
bien y sont aussi ah ouais
duboscq est un gros con mais ya pas de
même mais comment vous le savez
un gage au la carte finition vous devez
accepter l'invitation de collecte pour
aller dans son émission la semaine
prochaine le problème avec arthur l'a1 à
oui parce que moi j'ai promis arthur que
je n'irai pas voir qu et solidarité m
c'est sur wii
ouais mais le lâcher obligé à laisser un
petit peu obligé oui arthur si tu
regarde l'émission d'ardisson j'ai
oublié désolé j'accueille geneviève de
fontenay lycées monde
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
geneviève de fontenay lycée monnet quel
bonheur et vous avoir tous ici ce soir
pour cette dernière émission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà alors j'aime bien venir j'ai un
petit risque zéro au coeur gros et c'est
vrai je m'en rappelle j'ai dû venir la
première fois en 98 escota 1900 et on a
rigolé ensemble sans hésitation oui il y
en a eu des bons moments je dirais que
je te remercie parce que je crois que tu
as contribué à la popularité que j'ai
mal
vous détruire les uns
ar élec tout est bon aussi dakar jean
louis masson grande jamais je ne viens
la souffrance fait ok c'était résident
de st parc de paray à l'accident
[Musique]
on a passé des bons moments ensemble et
si tu te rappelles le petit mot que tu
m'avais mis un jour normal je jouais
très bien je vais me jeter mon secret
voilà il m'avait dit geneviève je t'aime
en secret beaucoup touché et en ce qui
concerne thierry je te remercie parce
que tu as toujours accueillis j'ai eu
marre et va encore il ya quelques temps
subi il ya un truc que j'ai jamais fait
non non non quand même pas
[Applaudissements]
m
google comme ça s'appelait louis un
mariage c'est permis ouais tu embrasses
bien est encore pire que le rouge à
lèvres sur les lèvres
je vous remercie aussi catherine
[Musique]
shaghai maintenant benoît 16 rebonds pas
lui avait promis qu'il viendrait
je sais il gare sa harley ils arrivent
en suisse yahia rituel dans cette
dernière émission c'est que les invités
pose une question alors en est à moi en
commençant par mois c'est normal je
t'écoute geneviève
j'ai pas tellement de questions à poser
mais j'étais venu pour te remercier way
avant tout posera une question c'est le
moment ou jamais est-ce que tu m'aimes
oui je sais ce que je suis en fer genève
ah oui mais on est sûr que tu dis là
c'est un jeu là c'est la marolle demi
molle la de fontenay la célèbre pâte est
chaude
non je suis suis très touchée ce soir tu
vois non mais c'est pas très jeune vlc
patrie v6 parce que quand même bon c'est
vrai que les bons moments sur une femme
a vécu des bons moments ensemble assez
mais j'espère qu'on continue les
saloperies 1 je vais commenter
l'élection de miss univers sons paris
première soirée des nuits du 24 juillet
alors il paraît une question à thierry
ardison question à l'ombre
thierry pour ceux indiqués
[Musique]
oh ben moi qu'elle n'essaie pas vrai
c'est depuis notre temps que laisse
parler les syndicats basile ça je gagne
un peu de temps pour trouver ma question
m'a dit l'invoquer la miss france qui
t'a le plus marqué non c'est lui qui
pose la question quelle est la miss
france qui t'a le plus marqué elodie
gossuin parce qu'elle a des couilles
l animal quel est l'animal est petit dl
avec des petites plumes et vol comment
s'appelle-t-il j'ai envie d'un ceux-là
je pensais aux parents je me suis moi
c'est sur une fausse piste
il est vraiment
en passant volontaire et libre est en
tournée avec votre spectacle
elie semoun se prend pour qui tu as fait
et vous serez du 22 septembre 10 octobre
ou à l'olympia bien sûr bien sûr un
grand classique je dirais tu vois là
vous aurez pu faire tout le monde en
parle des buts 7e rang et puma voilà je
t'annonce que l'émission s'arrête alors
c'est pour sa bonne santé monsieur de
carolis extraordinaire dans votre
spectacle c'est votre capacité à
interpréter successivement des
personnages très différents les uns des
autres rapports à gérard qui ne s'est
joué qu'un rôle
on assiste et vous avez dit sérieusement
vous avez dit comme clara morgane il ya
plusieurs personnes en moi un g10 un
très joli ça c'est moche l'attitude que
tu as enfin bon c'est vrai que c'est le
seul point commun que je peux avoir avec
elle du plaisir voilà tout à fait bien
les choses qu elle oui mais moi je fais
l'amour avec deux mille personnes tous
les soirs je sais pas peut-être pas 2000
souffle était au cap d'agde il ya un
personnage que j'adore c'est kevin ah
voilà on va faire une interview kevina
sa vue kevin na salut ça va ça te
dérange pas si je te tutoie kevina non
sévères telles quasiment l'âge de mon
grand père
kalyna je sais qu'à une grosse poitrine
pour ton âge à oued souf ah oui fait
1,66 à ces pages et ce féculent âge
maintenant balade iso dans quatre ans je
rêve un an là où est présent aucune
classe science n 2 parce que j redoublé
trois fois le ce2 cm par an considère
que je suis trop mûrs et écoute quoi
comme musique en ce moment kevin à un
badigeon je télécharge tout sur internet
alors je sais pas trop
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et dix mois kevin était allé voir mes
derniers concerts de justin timberlake à
paris je sais j'ai une copine qui était
alors gistré tout le concert son
téléphone que ce qu'elle a un forfait
neo et tu veux faire quoi plus tard
kevin à ouchy pas j'aimerais bien être
une star c'est magali tu t'intéresses à
la politique et bina away jeu disons je
pense que l'année prochaine je veux très
pur pour nicolas royal et ségolène
ségolène sarkozy je suis pas tu
t'entends bien avec tes vieux western
s'engage maintenant gars avec ma mère
mais mon beau père c'est un connard elie
semoun tu aimes bien il s'est mouillé
ouais j'aime bien j'aime bien son hymne
aux chaînes bien disons pour moi c'est
le meilleur comique de ces générations
bosc il aime bien plus beau et trop beau
il ressemble à alain delon mais en plus
vieux et tu crois que sans ces lentilles
bleues ils auraient fait la même
carrière franck dubosc non je connais
moi bah ouais j'ai toujours avec cadres
à changer de mains carrick icade kaba
way and 1 1 c'est elle qui avec m
[Applaudissements]
il a amené jean et tour jules pour la
saint-valentin kevina haoues on a été
dans ce restaurant américain mc do on
vous embrasser sur la bouche avec ton
mec ou non non c'est juste des snacks
mais pas la langue
ah non juste avec mon chien vous avez
jamais couché ensemble en fait non je
couche qu'avec mes peluche pour
l'instant et ça fait quoi d'apprendre
que britney spears était maman kevina
les mamans oui c'est génial
qu'est ce que tu fais après l'émission
kelina ben je rentre chez moi
pourquoi tu as quelque chose à me
proposer une soirée au baron ah ouais
super j'adore la grande bourgeoisie moi
mais c'est toi
bonsoir carte interdiction vous êtes
interdit démission appelé quartier
pendant un an
c'est pas possible c'est impossible on
les adore si on est dedans nous tous les
deux c'est un peu un autre
[Applaudissements]
il ya et bien sûr une carte où il ya
interdit d'arthur pendant un an et pour
lui c'est pas possible on attendait
lundi l'émission de la rentrée vous avez
une émission à rentrer meilleur tu
abandonné ses gardes et les a gardés
pour l'instant je vois les retourner là
bas je vous rappelle
[Musique]